[Musique]
voilà des visages connus du conseil
départemental qassam et axel travail à
la direction des moyens généraux votre
travail consiste à gérer la sonorisation
la projection et la visioconférence des
différentes salles du palais de la sauce
pas des grands communicants mais leur
action est essentiel au bon déroulement
des réunions de la collectivité et
depuis peu ils ont la même passion
cette passion du travail n'a pas la même
origine
axel étant un peu responsable de
l'engagement de kassam depuis une
dizaine d'années qu'on travaille
ensemble on parle il parle souvent du
marché du travail du coup on a fait nous
sortis ensemble et ce qui me marque me
suivez on m'a motivé de m'inscrire à mon
propre état et le travail des anglais
ce matin-là le trail des anglais et la
première course de qassam
mais bien d'autres agents du département
s'aligne sur cette épreuve
[Musique]
l'occasion du débat tenait pas quand
milan ouais mais pourrait mener à une
équipe au nez
[Musique]
bon tu vois pour l'instant ça va
pour l'instant on verra après ça tombe
bien contenu la gestion des 26 km de
course sous un soleil de plomb n'a pas
été la même
mais tous ont trouvé les ressources pour
avancer ses côtés contre heureux
c'est la curée haut c'est vrai c'est un
concurrent c'est un collègue c'est quoi
la et n'aura pas tant mieux trois fleurs
et par l'émission est très beau ça oui
c'est beau soit qu'il a râlé dans cette
aventure folle gestion doit pas rater
[Musique]
les dalles désorganiser la chaleur
suffocante rien n'arrête la
détermination de saisir bah ouais
compromis est en vue
bon allez
le beau sentier aménagé par les agents
du département et le cadre de cet
exploit
dans
rescapés devront suivre ouais tu vois
les atomes non à l'arrivée
[Musique]
c'est jouable
je sais c'est dur c'est bien quand même
âge écran programme je peux pas t cas ça
m'a tout donné
pourquoi avoir exploré cet univers aride
pourquoi se faire si mal pourquoi aller
au bout de cette volonté indomptable
[Musique]
mais lorsqu'il voit la ligne d'arrivée
qassam trouve la réponse angle route
[Musique]
on peut tout l'arraché maintient au
patron fouet par an
j'y emmène toujours axel notamment mené
la danse pendant le parcours hui en côte
d'ivoire est elle arrivée beaulieu
[Musique]